e
there we go good afternoon everyone a
quick prayer to start us off Lord in
heaven we come before you offering our
thanks for bringing us together safely
sometimes it is easy to forget that our
safe AR arrival and departure is a Grace
from you as we prepare for this meeting
we ask that you be with us may our
thoughts be led by you and our
conversations be inspired by you help us
to put our own agendas to the side and
seek your will and outcome for this
meeting please grant us wisdom in times
of uncertainty and Clarity in times of
confusion lead us to Solutions and help
us strengthen us as a group in Jesus
name amen please be
seated welcome to uh this October
council meeting uh we will get right
underway do we have any apolog
apologies there appear to be none uh
Declarations of conflict of interest
Council thank you your worship I wish to
declare a
non-financial conflict in relation to
the two items that are in the agenda in
relation to the district plan um not
that I uh am firmly of the belief that I
do have a conflict but I'm declaring it
for
transparency and to avoid um any issues
moving forward so I will be stepping
back from the table um in the public and
the public excluded parts of the agenda
for those two
items thank you councilor uh councelor
Dixon I worship I follow suit as well
for the same
reasons as counselor
hell thank you counselors did we have
any further
conflicts thank you very
much on to confirmation of
minutes uh we have the confirmation of
minutes of the ordinary meeting held on
Tuesday the 12th of
September oh we're
doing did we have any Miss issues with
those
minutes could I have a move that those
are true and
correct councel H seconded by councel
PHS any further comments or
questions I'll put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is carried uh minutes of the eth
an infrastructure meeting held on
Tuesday the 5th of
September did we have any questions or
comments can I please ask for a mve that
those are true and correct uh councelor
gine seconded by councelor
Fraser any further
comment I'll put the motion all those in
favor please say I and
against I
was
not could I please get a different
second if that is the case councelor
Stringer I'll put the motion again all
those in favor pleas a i and against
motion is carried thank you
counselors uh confirmation of the
minutes of the community well-being held
on Tuesday the 26th of
September did I have any comments from
that
meeting could I please have a mover that
was there that they are true and correct
councelor Dixon seconded by councelor
Reed any further
comments all those in favor please say I
and against motion is carried and
finally the meeting of the policy and
Regulatory commit committee meeting on
Tuesday the 3rd of October
any changes on here
counselors there appear to be none could
I a mover that is TR correct councelor H
second by counselor
mcdell if there's no further comment I
will put the motion all those in favor
please say I and against the motion is
carried thank you
councilors moving on to Urgent late
business do we have any urgent late
business
appears to be none we shall move on uh
now it's not on the agenda uh but we did
have a request uh for a presentation in
the public forum portion of the meeting
um which is usually at the beginning of
meeting so I will ask either Terry or
jinny to come up um for a f minute
presentation um I just will preface that
um it will be a five minute presentation
followed by um couple minutes for
questions and comments um but per our
standing orders we can't debate the
topic um or creating new
recommendations coming
up
oh thank you thank you very
much um this is my presentation um
relates to the the long-standing council
dispute you worship the mayor Mr B C
counselors and chief executive Mr
Perry we're here today to explain the
Public's need for closure on the
long-standing dispute within Gore
District
Council we believe the effect of the
dispute on the public as not at present
being enough consideration by the
Council we also want to propose a method
to restore the Public's faith in their
elected
representatives now that a planned
external review has been
abandoned
incidentally if you believe the cost to
rate payers as a barrier to this review
We suggest you Institute a random survey
of rate payers on this
topic the problem the public very much
needs to be reassured that there will
not only be no reversion to the
long-standing dispute but also no
reversion to the alleged culture of
bullying at both management and
government level governance level at
Gore District Council they need to be
assured that robust policies and
practices will be put in place to deal
with both these
matters also it needs to be acknowledged
that a serious amount of time time at
least 8 months was marred by the the the
dispute even though the council
apparently performed business as usual
the dispute was uppermost in the minds
of both Council and Community the whole
flavor at this time was anxiety for the
public the
solution please note this applies only
to elected persons
how can this reassurance to constituents
be provided without a
review we think public apologies are the
way you can show good faith to your
constituents the apologies should follow
these guidelines one a public apology by
the counselors alone to Mr Bell for any
stress he may have suffered during the
dispute such an apology is likely to be
much appreciated by your
constituents as Mr Bell has gained much
support and popularity during the
dispute note that a president has
already been set by Mr bot Bell's
apology to both counselors and chief
executive Mr Perry for stress both these
parties claim to have
experienced also councilors have
apologized to Mr Barry Mr Perry sorry
for his
stress two a public apology by the
councilors alone for both the time the
dispute has taken up and for erosion of
the Public's trust this apology need not
require Mr Bell's
participation because he's already
apologized to the public for erosion of
trust after the public opinion survey in
July
also circumstances during the dispute
did not enable him to keep his entire
focus on Council business and on
settling in as new
meor these Apologies by councilors would
we believe have two positive
outcomes one show that the councilors as
public Representatives take public
accountability seriously and are
prepared to listen to their
constituents two show that they are
prepared to move on in a more productive
way and genuinely regret the dispute and
their part in it all this we believe
could be achieved without embarrassment
on the part of any
individuals in summary what we need is a
new beginning a clean slate if you will
and a better way of moving forward
whereever everyone is respected
including
constituents are there any questions
thank you very much for your time I
appreciate that any questions or
comments from
councilors no questions or comments we
will move on thank you very much for
your presentation appreciate
it
next up on the
agenda next up on the agenda we have the
petitions on trees in the main
street did we have the petitioner here
Peter Woods did you want to come up and
speak to it at
all yeah I think that would be helpful
for
counil oops
well mayor and counselors someone going
to ask me some
questions cool we'll leave that as uh
read uh we will open up to the floor uh
councelor
McKenzie Peter um you've obviously done
a lot of treating of the streets the
main Street was there any business
people staff that actually said we want
the trees there no there was about two
places it's they said they like trees
that was it but the rest I went
round they didn't want the trees and it
was some of the workers that were there
you know they signed it as well but I
didn't go to any people on the street
yeah just to the shops so it was mainly
business owners in the business owners
and maybe some
staff thank you thank you councelor any
further questions uh councelor
mcf yeah just for your worship um thank
you Peter for taking the time to do this
um I think it's one of the things that
uh we seem to be seeing a little bit of
in our in our fa Town um getting P
petitions brought to us and also know
that um you've been uh fa
um active in other parts and changes
when we've done in in Gore um I think
you when I spoke briefly to you in the
in the gallery there you had a question
that you wanted to ask us in regard to
replacement trees and I'm not sure
whether it's correct for him to be able
to ask that question or not but I may be
able to ask the question for for Peter
um and and Keith may be able to give us
an answer just in regards the the the
cost of the replacement trees that we've
got in the main street at the moment was
that the query M I'm not sure whether
I'm putting on the spot or not Keith but
do we do we know what that
is Sor um just through to to counselors
um I think a figure of
$50,000 has been banded around the
community and um it's fair to say that
um that's that's probably Way Way Off
the Mark really um I can't give you an
exact figure but um I would think it's
around um 8,000 66 to $8,000 per tree
and and some of that is obviously
because of the um engineering uh and
structural elements that are involved in
the tree cells um so it's um trying to
contain the roots of a new tree so we
don't have issues with interference
um around um underground services and
then the other um aspect is that um
there's tree cages and grates which um
protect the trees so again they're
um
they relatively expensive
yeah U thank you Keith um yeah I really
just appreciate you coming coming in and
uh take the opportunity to present that
to us um and just further on to say that
I know that uh during the streets live
campaign they say that word
um that Peter gave us some very very
good advice um and some practical advice
around the streets and War and there one
of the uh almost out of statement from
all the town he has plenty of knowledge
about that too so that was appreciate
okay thank you if you need but I think
that's a lot of weight payers money
50,000 a tree my rates went up a lot and
that's a lot of
money for for clarification I think it
was six 6 to 888 ,000 a tree and just
six 6 to 8,000 a tree was it yeah and
and running just quickly running the
numbers here um it would work out to
about if you're doing a leaveing trees
about 66,000 for the entire lot rather
than per individual tree yeah
you
okay Council M sorry Peter hey thanks I
just want to add to this I've actually
stood where you are or sat where you are
in a petition to get rid of the last
trees so I'd like to share with what you
were thinking here so I can understand
what you're coming from and I have
canvased the retailers as well because I
was one for 20 OD years standing
sweeping cleaning and watching the the
the the last trees ruin the roads and
the foot path and people tripping over
and things like that so I am worried
about what's going on um I've asked a
lot of the the the retailers about what
not all of them wanted Parks they a lot
of them liked the idea of a plot of some
sort they didn't want trees but they
wanted something so so they weren't all
against the foliage or whatever but the
key thing is the cost is one part the
foliage is one of the things keep I need
to ask because it isn't a crab apple
tree which will drop the fruit and and
the leaves and that was one of the key
things getting in the gutters into the
shops onto the foot paths and things
like that uh a lot of people say why
can't we have Evergreens you know they
um I'm not an expert on trees but God
knows I've read enough about crab apple
trees in the last week to last lifetime
but they were asking that and a lot of
them felt that that was one of the key
things you know is it you know we're
putting trees back where they were
before the last trees I was told 10
years ago and Keith you can verify this
that the trees were fit for purpose the
Redwood ones now they come along and
took them out because they weren't fit
for purpose so I'm asking on behalf of
the rate payers is this going to be re
are we going to revisit this in another
10 years time with the same
issue just comment to that one um yeah
the the trees that have gone in so far I
think we've put three in in front of the
um B and z and in that section
um it's been a carefully considered
decision and and it did come before
Council twice so 2021
2022 um they're a mediumsized tree um
with with a flow um good Autumn color
and also Berry
um I guess the previous trees were
um what they talk about a apical
dominance but they um wanted to grow
skywards um at a which is typical of um
conifers really and so they they were
growing upwards into the line so what
we've planted is a is a mediumsized tree
with a sort of cola or pyramid type
shape so it's um unlikely to be uh an
issue going forward the the other aspect
really was around that sort of root
damage to the carriageway and things
like that and um that's where we're
using the latest technology which is the
the root cells so it's trying to contain
um you the roots in a in a manageable
fashion with
they thank you for that just wanted to
make sure you I hear what you say Peter
yeah well I think that the when I went
round to people
they all wanted Parks they weren't
saying they wanted trees there was only
four people that probably said they they
like trees but that was it the rest all
wanted parks for people to go to their
shops to try and get more money cuz when
you go up the street now there's not too
many
parks it's a lot busier than it used to
be thank you for that Peter sorry just
to follow up on the crab apple question
I was quite interested to get an answer
on that is there a issue with them
potentially falling into drains and
things like that or just I'm curious on
that point that Paul made yeah I think
the um just just in comparison to the
previous tree the um I think there was
big issues with the Dawn Redwood had a
very fine leaf that um would blow into
shops which which was probably an issue
but also got into spouting and ging so
um the you know the the the um crab
apple is deciduous so it will drop some
Le but
it's probably a whole lot um it's a
whole lot smaller as a tree specimen so
it's there'll be a lot less leaves
involved so much less of a problem than
what we've had
previously thank you Kate do we have any
more questions for Peter I just want him
sit down if we're just going to discuss
amongst ourselves did you have a
question for Peter himself or
counc I I have a question for Mr
hesler if I may
or do you want me to wait no that's fine
I'll just let Peter did you want to sit
down we'll continue talking um and and
there are two issues here one one is the
um whether you've got trees or not and
secondly is a desire to have more
parking and um interested in any
feedback Mr hazler can give us and and
happy birthday maray um in terms of the
um any pressure that's on parking in the
Main Street um do we actually have a
shortage of parking
uh through your worship um we well I
haven't received uh any what any um
requests for extra parking in the Main
Street um that I can recall uh and so I
I don't think there's a a
widespread um uh desire for extra
parking or it's definitely not being
conveyed uh to to council staff um so
what was the other part of your question
k um no that that was sufficient I think
if if um council is of a mind um to um
progress thing issues arising from this
petition that we possibly need a formal
survey carried out to actually look at
um the extent to which parking is
adequate in the main
street thank you councelor councelor
dexon and councelor
Reed
thank you
worship um I just have some comments to
make because I've done quite a bit of
research around trees and urban areas
and it's actually been calculated that
customers will spend up to 40% more time
in shops and lingering around shops when
there are trees in the area because that
the less it makes the atmosphere less
stressful more biodiverse cleaner air
reduce noise cooler and Summer for
people who need shade and um and it's
really good for coling collecting storm
water so having those trees and those
green areas are um to me are important
in a town and also I know that people
come into our town and they really do
admire the ambience and they love the
trees and the gardens and so I really
think that we need to think very clearly
about this but can I also add too that I
think that Council needs guidelines
around petitions for the future because
this petition doesn't have addresses it
only has names and signatures so um I'd
like to see some guidelines around that
because both or all the petitions we've
had are not um they haven't got any
guidelines there's nothing to look at on
their website very much either thank you
thank you Council dexon just for
clarification on that there is a section
in our standing orders around petitions
um but it is we can always relook at our
standing orders to make petitions more
rigorous it is based on the template
across the country of how to deal with
petitions but um fully take your comment
uh councelor Reed thank you Mr Mayor um
I agree with councelor Dixon um it's a
council policy at the moment to have
trees replaced and um I'm fully
supportive of it and along with glenis I
uh I like the Ambiance on the Street I
understand the retailers can get a bit
um annoyed with and they did with the
dawn redwoods but they are now gone so
moving forward I do have a question for
um Keith our manager um it did say in
your letter back to Mr Woods that
retailers had been engaged with um was
that retailers where the trees were
actually being um
replaced yes I um just answering your
question the um I think at each stage of
removal we've we've done a letter drop
which has been um um through our commun
Communications Department and I've I've
personally delivered those letters so um
and and it's I've either handed them on
to a staff member or to the to the owner
of a store and um in between time there
has been dialogue with a number of the
uh retailers o over the you know I can
think of um
a couple of them one of the chemists and
also one of the cafes uh where the you
know I think the cafe bought he bought a
about 20 photos in of his gutters and um
problems problems with the leaves um so
you know there has been a ongoing
dialogue thank you but further to that
then there hasn't actually been anybody
that says I do not want a tree planted
in front of my property not directly to
me thank
you thank you councelor Reed any further
questions or comments on this topic
councelor
Stringer uh through you you worship
um
providing if the trees grow up and they
don't do or perform the way they're
expected um where does the council's
liability s if they end up damaging like
getting leaves into gutters and and
causing damage like the old trees did
where does it sit with us cuz I know as
a a farmer if we've got trees on our
side of the property and they hang out
over pair wise and fall down we're
liable but doesn't go back the other way
and and it is on a side of a state
highway as
well you got any easy questions
counselor um no good question look I
don't want to give a categoric answer on
liability of the fly but what I can can
tell you is that uh generally speaking
our approach with
trees uh on road reserve and this isn't
the case if they become problematic we
address the issue uh and if there was
you know no one damage to a property um
obviously would have a case to answer
I've never dealt with one where there's
actually damaged a property but
certainly trees that are causing uh
property nuisance uh we have in the past
and I can recall
distinctly um the senior citizens Club
at one stage we were if we're not we may
still be doing it cleaning out the
spouting of a tree that they found
problematic but the public at large
thought was was was worthy of um
preservation um generally speaking I
mean there are we do have some trees
that were planted many years ago uh and
some have become challenging shall we
say because PL in a place where there's
Urban Development now and I guess um if
I off top of my head the large Redwood
in Devon street is one that um it's it's
an issue that will probably need to be
addressed at some stage by Council uh
it's probably beyond the contemplation
of most parties that you would have a
not the Redwood sorry it's the um well
anonia the well anonia and it's massive
and it's completely out of scale with
its environment um but it's a beautiful
tree uh but at this stage you can see
it's it's caused you know some up
lifting ground um but in the main we
just work with adjoing property owners
and I guess the the removal of the trees
in Main Street was an answer to the
request of of the people saying these
are ill suited Keith with his fres of
eyes saw that and uh decisively
recommend the council for remove those
trees and here we are but in terms of
absolute liability for damage no I would
not prepared to give you off the cuff uh
categorical answer in a public forum at
this stage thank you
thank you Steve and thank you Council
supplementary through worship want to
make a suggestion then if if we're
trying to repase both parties that we go
for like a bonsai type system at a
larger scale and those crates that we
have out there currently on the foot
path where we have a tree that we can
take from the parking lot and put away
in storage somewhere while it does its
um annual
molting
a fe idea counselor don't know if Keith
has any feedback on that I won't put him
under that
Spotlight any further
comments I have the feeling we've got a
bit of a Split Chamber at the moment of
so far we've heard from two counselors
who would like a little bit more uh
survey information and two counselors
who are happy to proceed as we
are did we have any other comments
around the table
around the way we want to go would we
like to move with the recommendations
that are WR
there councelor Phillips I'll move the
recommendations as written you
wish is
written to we have a second for that
motion councelor
Reed motion is now for
debate does anyone have anything they'd
like to
add so just for clarification uh the
recommendation is that the petition will
be received uh that the cons Council
will consider this matter with the
respect to the previous resolutions
passed by the council in September 2021
and July 2022 and the council note any
changes to the pre previous decisions
with range with reasons for the changes
and resolve record its decisions
accordingly so as it stands there would
be no changes is that the the
recommendation called Council
H yes so in terms of the recommendation
that we've got um we can if if it's the
view around the table that I'm picking
up that we um uh stay with the status
quo in terms of the plan that's there
the only recommendation that required as
the petition be
received because the other two actually
are asking us to discuss
it um and take no further action and
effect I would describe them as
nugatory having no legal
standing that's a that's a fair point I
think the the second recommendation more
acknowledges that Council have discussed
this two times before and that we
sticking with those
recommendations uh my personal views are
that I don't see any harm in in talking
to the public again um people are
allowed to change their minds and we're
allowed to look into those but those are
that's just my my opinion I respect the
the views around the table of of wanting
to
proceed so we have a motion on the table
do we have any further
debate uh councelor mcone um all
I think one of the key things out of
this whole piece is that obviously the
consultation Keith that you've done um
possibly from the people I spoke to
didn't it didn't maybe it hasn't got
through to everyone and that they the
retailers and business people feel
particularly that they haven't been
listen to and we do that at our Peril
we've got to listen to the rate payers
of the town and find out what they're
wanting and we're doing the best we can
for what we we are I understand that and
I don't hate TR
I think they're great but I think that's
the key thing a lot of the people think
they haven't been listened to and that's
that's an issue in itself so it's just
all want to say thank
you well see councelor uh Council
M it looks a bit of a tandem team here
but um we haven't actually discussed
this PRI surprisingly enough um you I'll
probably agree with councelor P mcf that
um after talking to realizing coming
here and talking to some of the
businesses I think there probably is a
situation here where we need to go back
and reaffirm with some of those
businesses because there was clear
commentary came through um both to
myself and obviously we now have a
partition uh with those that have gone
through those signatures just to assure
that we are actually um following the
correct process with the business and
that's not uh all beit the fact that we
do have an amazingly beautiful Main
Street and that regardless of whether
the trees are there and the gardens and
the and the fact that it is a
centerpiece but we need to listen to
that community and there was an
indication here um that if we just move
straight on over this there's going to
be a number of people and businesses on
the Main Street believe we haven't we we
haven't listened and I think we as a
council need to get that re reaffirmed
back to us before we continue on um
that's my opinion and I know the the
recommendation here makes just a we bit
confusing how you would do that whether
we need to um just possibly um do an
amendment to the recommendation that uh
for the council to be reassured that it
is appropriate to continue to proceed
the way it is I just go with councilor
uh Fraser and then Council McKenzie and
then we'll Circle back to whether there
wants to be an amendment around the
table so
Council uh three worship thank you look
I'm um I was straight out there I do not
like trees near houses as simple as that
they can cause so much damage and I know
you're trying to keep them in a sale and
everything else about that but it's not
going to stop wind blowing and rubbish
going into the into buildings um do we
need more parks and g i I actually don't
think so but it is something and and I
agree with both the council mcfs that
we've got a petition here of business
owners on the Main Street hot telling is
absolutely different to what has come
back out through to us so I honestly
think we need to go back back and a
little bit
more thank you councelor councelor
Mackenzie I I'm basically agreeing with
what you three folk have said um I'm not
pro or anti- trees but we have to be
seen to be listening to the business
people in the
town and taking note of what they're
saying no matter what the outcome is
we've got to be seen to be listening to
them and not just you know ignoring them
for one of a better
term thank
you thank you Council McKenzie councel
Dixon thank you worship I think we need
to know how many parking spaces are
actually taken up by trees in the main
street because I don't think it is a lot
actually and i' I drive through the Main
Street quite often and I can't see cars
up and down every side of the main
street parking um I I think we need to
survey that part of it really and and um
just listen to I do think we need to
listen to the retailers but I worked on
the Main Street and swept the street
when I was a junior for many many years
and there's a lot more rubbish on the
Main Street and on the foot path than a
few leaves I have to
say thank you counselor it seems like
the conversation's progressed slightly
oh uh Sonia did you want to comment um I
just through the chair would like a PL
of clarification um any surveys would
that just be retailers or general public
given that the general public are great
users of our main street just if you're
formulating a
recommendation sorry just further
clarification from that Ona what would
that look like in terms of surveying the
general
public uh through the Cher again will we
can run run a um quick consultation
Community engagement that would reach um
not only retailers but also our
residents through our usual channels uh
so through usual channels not as in
people walking on the street and asking
how they feel is that there could be
various we could come back with a bit of
a plan if you'd like cool thank you
Sonia do we hear counc
Phillips thank you worship um I've
listened to everybody talking and I and
I
I understand um that uh the the people
that look after their shops are getting
sick of the trees but I believe it's a
districtwide solution if if the if the
district doesn't want the trees in the
main street of
Gore then let them tell us but at
currently at the moment it's only the
business people are telling us and we're
not certain that they were weren't were
not told um and I think that uh the
reason why people VIs
a town is because of the beautiful
location the beautiful town that we have
and I believe that the the staff have
gone out out of their way this time
around to make sure that the trees that
are planted are going to be
lasting fit for purpose not destroy
infrastructure and done a lot of work
and um yeah I'm just thinking that uh
maybe maybe we're just going to go go
ahead and waste their time and Survey
everybody and find the the solution is
that they want to the trees kept in the
main
street thank you counselor uh I do think
there could be an outcome uh but I do
hear around the table that they still
want to ask that question to the
community based on the petition uh so
with that being said uh can I suggest an
amendment somewhere along the lines of a
survey of both local uh community
members as well as retailers as well as
uh Council Dixon's comment around what
the parking is and maybe some rough cost
estimates to to how much it's so further
report to that nature is that kind of
what I'm picking up around the table as
an
amendment councelor re further just
before that I'd like to ask U Mr mcroy
another question if I may
please if there was um if it came back
that they don't want trees on the Main
Street we've already going going to to
have um the containers paid for ready to
go the trees done how many more actually
need to go in the Main Street between
the police station corner and down as
far as um I don't know where the W sheet
statue is um at the current time we've
got six um holes on the Main Street so
that that that does be beg the question
um as to what we do with hols on Main
Street um I I guess our timing um just
through um accessing contractors and
things like that um and and having staff
available has delayed this process um um
had we not had a delay the trees would
have been in there we wouldn't probably
be discussing this um but there's
another five trees on the Main Street so
that and and the the next five are
really down down this end of the main
street so in front of um carnaby cars um
Kentucky Fried Chicken and and then I
think across the road so um yeah the the
yeah the demand for parks of the end of
the Mind street is as least than you
was thank
you thank you
Council any further comment or would
someone like to move an
amendment or would we like to put the
motion cancel the CL
just to keep this moving we obviously
um sort of going round and around a we
but um if we uh did the amendment but
the only thing is
that I'm just
thinking as I'm talking uh if we do an
amendment around the uh the basis of
getting the
um the decision reviewed on the previous
Council obviously what we've done on the
previous Council
um are we stipulating that where this is
where are we removing the previous the
trees that are already in there or we
going to remove the whole lot because I
notic some have talked about all the
trees at the Main Street I think we're
talking about some specific trees here
the replacement trees um you know how
refined do we have to get um or are we
better running with this recommendation
and putting it to the boat and seeing
where where it goes to from there um to
to expediate it on
just wondering where we're going because
we could be creating a bigger hole than
sitting in the five ones of the main
street so for clarification and this is
just my understanding so happy to be
corrected here um but the recommendation
at stand is that the petition be
received so an amendment would include a
further recommendation around some sort
of survey um I'm not sure whether Sonia
would be a to break down a tree by tree
um survey as we go along um which we can
try but or I mean we can section them
off of we're only talking about the
trees past past a certain area um that
would also put a halt to everything
that's happening at the moment um it
would be in my view pointless to do a
survey as the trees are getting put in
anyway so that is's a clear
understanding of if we are to amend it
would help the operation until that
survey is done and then it would come
back to the council and then that's when
we would undo the recommendations at
earlier that have already been
passed when we have that further
information is that correct right yeah
bro you worship yes that's uh correct um
you've already got some work implemented
so so the decision you've previously
made has in part been implemented and
what you're already doing now is uh
calling a Hal uh pending further
consultation the nature of which you
want a plan I would take it from the
communications team of the council to
sign off on and then out to communicate
with to consult with the um the
community including obviously the
retailers and then back to the council
for an ultimate
decision and if that decision is
different from previous ones we can doal
with it at their
time thank you for that Steve was that
clear to everyone yeah councel as it
also clear too that if that goes ahead
we will have large holes in the Main
Street all through the main retail
period of the year will the retailers be
happy with
that that raises a good question
councelor for Keith when's the expected
completion of all of those
trees the the current um holes I think
there's one where there's an issue with
a um underground high voltage line which
is um causing us some issues um but the
the five trees that are
are able to go ahead would all be in by
the end of October so so failing that um
yeah we we were very mindful about the
um retailers Christmas trade and didn't
want to impact on
that thank you kaan very good point um
Council Reed uh councilor
hell so in terms of what council Reed
has there is a potential health and
safety issue um that needs to be
considered and appropriate steps taken
um so um for the sake of of enabling
moving forward there I'm proposing that
there be three recommendations the first
one that the petition be received the
second recommendation is that a survey
being
undertaken of
um owners and occupiers
of businesses in the Main Street and the
general public to ascertain their
views on uh the planting of trees in in
the section that we're talking
about the third aspect is um that
Council staff take appropriate action to
ensure that appropriate health and
safety is provided to
um people and vehicles in the affected
area you happy to move that Amendment
Council yes I will do we have a second
for that
amendment can I ask for a second to
first before a comment have it a second
uh Council
mcf so we have the amended
recommendation as read out before uh is
now open for debate Council
dexon you worship I um so that means
that these holes are going to stay there
all over the Christmas period um just
with fencing around them or whatever
it's all the planting of the trees is
going to be put on hold is that what
this
means potentially yes but U per the
recommendation we are asking Council
staff to look at the health and safety
risk of that option moving
forward so if I can just explain what
I'm intended by that motion um to
address the health and safety issues
fencing off is one option but does that
actually meet um the the test that's
needed it may well be that the holes
need to be filled in with gravel or
something else to provide um that is
easily removed at a later stage if need
be um in order to ensure that Vehicles
don't run in it or or people don't fall
into them or jump into them when it's
filled with water or something
else thank you for that clarification
counselor councelor
Fraser I'm going to do a complete toxy
Turvy here um a height I do not hate I
dislike trees near buildings but we've
got six holes in the ground this has
been passed by cancel resolution
previous I probably would have voted
against it but it has been passed we've
got everything done there what are we
going to get out of this at the end of
the day is six holes on the ground going
through Christmas and we probably going
to plant trees in them in January or
February um I understand the petition I
can understand what's going on there
seems to be a mix up or a
misunderstanding and what the public has
said to us but you know gain street is
does look great I agree with you
councelor Phillips it is people talk
about it all the time I just don't like
trees near buildings
but what are we doing here and what is
this extra cost going to be to us so
it's another
thank you councelor councilor Paul mcf
and then councel M sorry just I thank
you you worship we are living in under
democracy I believe and this is part of
it we're discussing something and we're
trying to work it out for the best for
the public of the town that we're
representing so we've got to go through
these things and if we have to hold it
up those trees will be here for 20 years
or Plus or maybe but we've got to look
at these things and I think it's
essential we do that thank
you thank you counselor councelor
mcf just um through worship obviously we
we've got the recommendation there we're
trying to work around it we've clearly
got a differing of opinions around the
table should we not instead of making
the amendment actually stick with the
motion that's the recommendation that's
there and see where the council actually
sits because it may be that the council
actually sits against um what some of us
are discussing so
um so procedurally from here we've got
the amendment on the table yeah I was
trying to allude to that prior to the
amendment being given in SEC if there's
not a further Amendment we'll put that
Amendment if that fails we'll go back to
the original motion if it passes then
that'll become the motion and we'll vote
on it again yeah thank you wish thank
you
councelor any further discussion feel
like we've had a pretty robust
discussion about
it councelor hoval did you feel
comfortable reading out your recommend
again before
I I'm hopeful that um our minute taker
um is able to read it out to us in
full um that the petition be received uh
that a survey be undertaken of owners
and occupies of businesses in the Main
Street and the general public to
assertain their views on the planting of
of trees in the section referred to and
that Council staff take appropriate
action to ensure that appropriate health
and safety is provided to people and
vehicles in the affected area I can
confirm that that is what I
said thank you Susan and thank you
counselor without any further debate I
will put the motion so by a show of
hands can I please get those in
favor one two three four five six seven
the amendment has passed it is now the
original it is now the motion at hand do
we have any further
debate your i m recorded as the gates
thank you uh when we get to when we pass
the actual motion absolutely council
phlips do we have any further
debate I will put uh the amended motion
all those in favor please uh say
I and against show of hands would you
like to be recorded
against there councelor Phillips Council
Dixon councel Gardine councel Reed and
councelor Fraser and the motion has
passed thank you councilors for that
robust
debate uh can I just make a
recommendation that to save all this
Hassle and petitions that we have a
program work sent to us in regardless to
the next lot of trees so at least we
know we can debate whether or not they
need to come down and and um save a bit
of time effort and money because I can
just see the money being spent here
doing doing it for absolutely nothing
and I apologize to the rers for doing
that uh thank you councelor I would
believe a program of work will be coming
as part of the ltp that's in terms of
activity management plans for future
works that will be consulted on is that
correct through your worship yes
although I think Council Phillips is
referring specifically to trees and
potential removal thereof uh we have a
tree uh policy and it's generally
policed very rigorously and trees are
pretty emotive subject um so if the
staff were
contemplating um for example removing a
series of trees or a a particular
significant tree would that significant
tree would require a resource consent
but any other trees if they were um
prominent they would be the subject of
um an approval process most likely
through the policy and Regulatory
committee because we recognize how
um emotional and potentially divisive
the issue can
be thank you Steve uh without any
further comment we will move on to item
six on page 41 the great health
statement of
intent
uh would the deputy chief executive like
to talk to this report at all nothing to
add thank you rcks uh any questions or
comments around the
table there appear to be
none oh councilor fras apologies uh
apologize and it's more of a comment
than anything else and I read through
this document and it's you know it's
magnificent loves the pictures and
everything the statements in it still
have a sad taste in my mouth about the
oat plant through Great South and the
lack of a full explanation that we've
had and then I read through this
document how forthcoming and no um what
the sort no tricks or jokes or not jokes
that's the wrong word but if you know
what I mean and then we put 10 to 12
years into a project that has just
flowing the C to Canterbury and I would
as a council surpris that we probably I
should have done something and said
something not asked for a bit bit of an
explanation about what had
happened uh thank you counselor just to
provide some context on that it is a
still a commercially sensitive um Topic
at the moment and I know that's not what
you want to hear um but from great the
Great South sheh holders committee we
have expressed as much as we possibly
can um on that issue councel
gine yeah I do have some issues with the
oat plant going north I'm a note grower
and um it's certainly not going to help
us but um commercially I can see the
reasoning behind it but also looked down
in the statement of comprehens Revenue
and expenses and I noticed that the cost
to us is going to rise as um
shareholders over the 3 years ahead and
uh then you look a way bit further down
in the space Ops operation is actually
making quite major profits and why are
we putting more money in when we already
getting no return
and um we've probably going to look very
hard in their budgets and their
long-term planning in the next we few
months and um we need to seriously look
at funding Great South whether we stay
there or pull
out thank you
Council
uh to that affect um the conversation
around the table and maybe in the joint
shareholders committee is that uh the
idea with space Ops is to continue to
invest as it grows
uh so that we can see Returns on it uh
in the future but fully take on on board
your comment to sort of provide a little
bit of context on Space Ops you might
comment as their input costs are going
up at the same time they're making
profits can as you can read in the
document thank you
counselor uh councelor Dixon thank you
worship um I'll just make a comment that
I'd like to see your Arts and Heritage
promoted more I look through through
this document and there's not a lot of
mention about it um but I believe the Fe
feasibility studies for the agricultural
department is is um is really
good into alternative land use I think
that is a that is a good
project thank you councilor Dixon uh to
your point around Arts and
Heritage um it is likely to be in the
recently released uh tourism destination
uh
strategy um it could could be in there
which I don't think we're receiving
today but I'm happy to
provide any further
discussion no could I pleas have get a
move that this report be
received
uh councelor uh Paul mcf and AER
councelor
Dixon any further
comments I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against motion
is carried thank you
counselors uh the spaceops statement of
intent uh may have been covered in the
last item
slightly do we have any
comments canel got on I think a
profitable company should return a
dividend uh fear Fair comment
councelor any further
comment could I piece of a move that
this report we
received uh councilor Philip seconded by
Council Fraser any further discussion I
will put the motion all those in favor
please say I and against the motion is
carried on to point number eight now on
page
86 the connected moku joint committee uh
did the chief want to talk to us very
briefly your worship um this is just a
point that Council hoval raised the last
meeting that while we were uh making
appointments to the uh appointment
committee we actually hadn't actually
resolv to um participate and establish a
joint committee so that particular
resolution will just close that Loop and
get everything
legitimate thank you for that Steve
Council
hav a stickler for process at some time
um so given that it hadn't been uh the
establishment of the Comm committee
hadn't been established is our previous
um resolution of the appointments also
need to be included as part of this so
that it's done in the correct
order through your worship for belts and
braces yes you could say that you
endorse and uh ratify the previous
Council resolutions uh in respect of
appointments to that joint committee so
your worship I'd like to move that the
recommendation be received plus that the
fur the recommendation is just outlined
by the chief executive then also be
included did we get that soon fantastic
D seconder councelor Phillips any
further discussion I will put the motion
all those in favor please say I and
against the motion is carried next up
number nine on page 93 uh petition for
the proposed bus service between Mata
and Gore did we have the petitioner
present
it doesn't look like it did the chief
executive want to speak to
this yeah thanks your worship um this
was received uh wasn't expecting it um
and uh as I mentioned in my report the
concept of a bus service between Mata
and gour murn has been uh talked about
it has been tried um a couple of times
previously in the past um 18 or so years
uh it has never found to be a
sustainable service that um both um with
the demand uh backing it up and also uh
mainly demand um but I recognize also
that times change uh the price of petrol
particularly has gone up and there could
well be um a different view in terms of
the depth of demand and the price uh
people are prepared to pay for a fear
for and the for what has been proposed
as a weekly service now my memory serves
me correctly the previous ideas were I
think two or three times a week uh so
this this could be a runner but really
this is the bread and butter of the
community board uh the community board
represent that community and we'll have
a better understanding what the the
issues and the demands are and so hence
the recommendation that it be obviously
the petition must come to the council
but I think in terms of investigation
and recommendation on future action
points the community board is your first
protocol thank you Steve counselors do
we have any questions or comments on
this
item I note that uh Nikki coats is in
the room as well so she's comfortable
being questioned as well um I'll allow
that too Council um just um I think this
highlights the issue
um brought up earlier um by councelor
Dixon in terms of providing information
as part of a petition um our um Council
website um is in general terms just
talking about how you process a a
petition but it doesn't have details of
what should be
included um so while in the case of the
previous petition I recognize some of
the names and and and um uh uh accepting
that a number of them are uh the owners
of business or operators in the Main
Street um I don't recognize Iz many of
these names um here in fact um some of
uh at least one is repeated one gives a
phone number of
111 um some of them are just first name
only given and therefore we're not in a
position of actually knowing whether
this is a legitimate um petition um I do
have some comments I'd like to make on
on the merits that are there and I'm
happy to come back to that or I can
express them now if you
wish I'm going to try and keep the two
issues separate because it was brought
up in the last one uh just for
clarification the only uh terms in here
is that the petition must be at least 20
signatures uh and must consist of uh
fewer than 100
words uh and petitions must not be
disect disrespectful use offensive
language include uh malice inaccurate or
misleading
statements uh so we we could definitely
look at our standing orders and um beef
that up a bit if if you like but we'll
keep those two issues separate um so if
we deal with the one in front of us and
we'll Circle back to that if that's
right Council if if I can just clarify
it's the council website information
that I feel needs to be updated not the
standing orders standing orders deals
with the process the information you're
providing should include the person's
name not just a squiggle of a signature
um their address and and any other
information they want to
include
to do that um I think it's I think we've
got to do both because if someone
doesn't follow what the instructions on
the council website per our standing
orders they're still entitled to give a
petition to that effect um so I think if
we're going to do one we do we do both
which we can we can crack open our
standing orders we we have the um the
availability to do that um we'll come
back to that issue um in front of us is
the bus service between mat and G uh
comments councelor
McKenzie uh through worship just a
comment um somebody may have more
knowledge than I but it didn't work in
the
past why would it work
now any answers to that I know fuel
costs have gone up but so has the cost
of running the service
obviously thank
you thank you
councelor councelor Reed um thank you Mr
Mayor I'm very happy for the Mata
community board to look further into
this as a Community um possibility and
and maybe just because of costs and
looking at whether or not a proper bus
maybe a mini bus may be available and
also maybe um talking to some
volunteer um people in your town like
lions that may be able to assist with
costs um just so that um it is there I
think
um I can remember as a young person
coming to gore on the express on a
Friday night so I know what it's like
when you can't you don't have access to
a car for some reason and for some
people that is beginning to become a
real issue so I'm happy to move the
recommendation and wait for feedback
from the matara
community uh the motion has been moved
we have a second councelor Dixon we will
continue the
debate uh councelor
Fraser um directed at you have you had
any residents in the community come and
approach isue about a bus
service
de
thank you Niki uh Council thank you
councilor Fraser councelor
Phillips thank you wish um the community
board chairs just uh highlighted um that
no one has come to the board yet and I
was a community board member in 2005
when we first instigated the first buses
to get between Gore and Mata it started
started off okay um um with a local bus
company uh then it just rled off in
about the first month and
um and potentially what what what can
happen is that we're just going to go
around in a circle because at the end of
the day the community board are going to
come back with a recommendation to you
to council at the next council meeting
for you guys to make the decision so I
believe you should just make a decision
tonight thank
you thank you councelor any further
comments councilor Rich mcf yeah uh just
for you a question for councilor
Phillips here actually so when when they
did the bus service last time it came
via community board like is it it came
through and why is this this one here
sort of gone round and just front it up
to
us uh perhaps you need to ask the
president who wrote the petition um we
we have not had contact with her about
the
yeah well while I understand that um and
I appreciate the chief executive's idea
about sending to the community board for
the recommendation um the we're only
going to come back to council saying
that our recommendation is that the G of
council Supply a bus service um through
its rate PS to pay for uh subsidized
transportation from Mata to gore and and
I'm looking around the room I can
guarantee what the answer is going to be
and and I just thinking about time's
prees and I go to the next community
board meeting and and Nicki and I've
already had a bit of a discussion about
this and know we've got better things to
discuss at the moment but I I understand
and receive the petition and if the
person likes to come and and have a
really good
discussion to the community board and
put a really good case together I'm sure
that we can work together and then bring
it to council with a better idea about
what it may cost who's going to run it
etc etc so until that time happens I
think we
just Rec um accept it and then move
on thank you
councelor
thank you
Nikki just to throw a complete spanner
into the works um I know that there's uh
a public fund that was released by labor
a couple of months ago uh around public
transport I do note that the G District
doesn't get any of that funding um
having not had any public transport um
just wondering with there have been
exploration from staff uh into trying to
get a piece of that fund um and also the
idea around potentially an electric van
as well um and what what whether that
may be an option
too uh not specifically you worship
we've um I mentioned my report C the
possibility of government funding and of
course uh public transport is being is
being funded uh a lot more expensively
and generously than what has H to been
the case with the current government I
guess what my report was trying to focus
on and what the no coach the chair has
um now commented on with some Authority
is the demand for such a service if the
demand is there um maybe there is
worthwhile investing some time in
finding funding sources but without the
demand I didn't think there was much
point in actually doing too much work um
U because demand will whatever funding
you get you still need to have the
requisite number of backsides on seats
and also a a user contribution to make
the whole thing work and that was where
the I was coming from in terms of
community board intelligence but you've
got that tonight and I suspect it's
Philly black and white you've got both
Niki coats and counsil Phillips saying
hey look we've done this and there's no
there's no discernable Community demand
for the service I think you're at
liberty to um make a call tonight
thank you stepen I think the key
component of that is current government
um that fund will exist in a week is uh
yeah neither nor there uh Council Dixon
thank you worship I'm just wondering is
this a regional council issue rather
than a district council issue because I
know that Regional councils run bus
services in other areas um yeah just a
thought correct me if I'm wrong his but
yes usually that is is the case um but I
think given South's demographic it can
be handled at at both both
levels uh
Mar microphone please thank
you uh through worship just to answer
that last question um normally it is the
Regional Council but in in the case of
Southland uh I Ino city council run it
because I the only uh TLA that that
actually has public transport um yeah so
that they would be the uh the body that
we would need to um to to uh negotiate
with um any funding for that public
transport
proposed thank you
Mar so the recommendation on the table
uh is to refer this to the community
board did we are we of the mind to split
those to
commendations so that we can vote on one
and the other CU one us just receed the
petition the second is to then refer it
on to the community
board I I would agree with it with you
in spitting the recommendation there is
absolutely no reason why we can't um
notify the community board about the
petition and put it on its agenda at the
next meeting and if the petition writer
wants to come and make it make a full
hearted discussion about and for us then
to go
ahead and bring to back to council
funding Etc that's fine but currently at
the moment we haven't had any discussion
that's just gone to council staff so
until that time comes well we don't
know uh totally understand your point
there counselor I think this
recommendation is quite specific in
terms of um as attaining the depth of
demand potential pricing and potential
shortfall um whereas what you're talking
about is more General conversation um
which we could change the recommendation
if we wanted to pass it on to the
community board but I feel like what I'm
sensing is that receiving the P will
suffice and then if they want to go to
the community board they're welcome
too I think the first part of the
recommendation is fine and then the
second part is and that the petition
referred to the community board that's
all you need to
put have to move that Amendment second
uh Council
Stringer any further discussion around
the amendment
no I will put the amendment all those in
favor please say I and against the
amendment is carried it is now the
motion do we have any further comment
around the new
motion I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is carried thank you counselors
another robust
debate moving on to Point number 10 uh
page 97 the proposed Gore District plan
request uh for extension of time and
consultation on period I'll just give a
moment for councel haval and councelor
Dixon to leave the
table and the chief executive would you
like to speak to this
report yeah thanks you wishop um I guess
I personally wasn't surprised to receive
this request for an extension of time um
the the broad plan of the council and
certainly the district plan subcommittee
was always targeted at uh notifying the
district plan midy year in in the winter
months but a couple of issues got
awareness and one of those of course as
I mentioned my report was the late uh
promulgation of the national policy
statement uh on biodiversity uh so that
needed a rapid um revision of some part
the plan to make sure that it was
compliant with that NPS so we basically
went from thinking we hoping to get it
notified end of June mid to Mid July to
suddenly into the end of August and then
you've got carving and then lamming and
um and is a very busy time for the for
the rural sector um it's this is a long
running project it will um be once a
district plan is in place it's there for
10 years
in practice and history tells us that in
a feat is probably 15 years by the time
you get through another review uh so the
loss of another month of consultation
and my humble view is neither here nor
there uh and the need for getting
everyone to have an opportunity to make
considered submissions and feel they
have had the opportunity to to put
forward their best um thoughts and
arguments and the right to be heard um
is is very important U while we might
the net effect might be L of six to8
weeks because of then you've got
Christmas and January as I said in my
report the upside is the property group
will have more time to actually um do a
summary of those submissions which have
to be publicized and you invite cross
submissions on those submissions um so
it'll put the hearings committee back a
couple of months in terms of getting
into gear and and and Away in hearings
but in my view uh the importance of full
public participation uh and not being um
hog tied to to what is a statutory
minimum and it can be extended is is
important so my recommendation is that
you accept the request and um let the
show
commments thank you Steve uh councilors
do we have any questions or
comments uh councelor gine yeah I would
agree I was on the district Comm um plan
committee and um has been it's a time it
takes a bit of getting your head round
and um for anyone to get their head
round and put a submission and it's
going to be take a bit of time and uh
people have asked for extension and I
think if we grant that extension it's a
lot of
Goodwill thank you counselor councelor
Phillips uh I'm also on the district
plan committee and I agree with their
with Council Gardine and and their
aspect is that as Urban counselor would
be uh unfair of me to not Grant the
farmers a little more extension time
because it was a very busy period time
for themselves and and I believe the
more submissions that we have the better
off and the better knowledge that we
have to make sure that we're making the
right decision because we're the first C
off the rank for this District plan for
the whole country so let's get it
right councelor uh rich mcf
yeah just for your worship uh you're
happy to support the recommendation
there and uh move if
required
um yeah clearly as the two other
councilors have indicated uh there would
be SE to be Goodwill and at the time uh
around the countryside in the landscape
we've got anything that we can look at
where we're cooperating um with the
primary industry group um particularly
uh with hardship and various things that
are happening within industry I think
it's a it's a a good move but also very
practical as well to engage in these
conversations and ensure that we are
getting uh enabling and getting uh
correct and valuable feedback on a very
important uh item so I'd be happy to
move that
recommendation thank you councelor and
respect uh counselor uh MD yeah I'll
second the motion recomend sorry the
recommendation thank you
counselor just be well it's now open for
debate on that
recommendation um going through this
report I do note that uh this is going
to extend the process by approximately
two
months uh I guess listening to our rural
friends is there any downside by
extending it by 3 months so adding that
two months into the consultation period
and allowing the rural folks to have
that time to submit over the Christmas
period because there's not my understand
is there not going to be a whole lot
done it's going to extend by two months
anyway why would we not include that in
the submissions
time might be a bit naive
Council I think if they haven't got
their act together by the end of
November December is a very busy time in
the farm too and people and businesses
like lawyers and um any advice would
just about shut up shop on you so
basically if you haven't got it done by
the end of November you've missed your
chance I mean I guess to that point we
would be more or less shutting up
shoping that period as well um so that's
why I I guess was making the case of why
not just keep it open so that those
people who can or do have available time
do some that um counselor
Fraser I'm um agreeing I'm agre with the
total motion of of moving it out um
because our rural sector primary
producers has been saying that Nan's
been listening to them anyway so um the
case of Goodwill the two months thing
it's neither here or there would that
put us through the chief ex would that
put us
behind well you would have I think off
top of the head uh counselor the the
property group that will be working
through they will be sort of uh just
spinning their heels waiting for the
submission period to close before they
can really start to construct a a sum of
the submissions received and they may be
waiting for an extra month with and you
might according picking up Council
guidelines point you might get a dribble
uh and they could have got onto their
work a lot sooner but you don't really
want to start doing a summary until
you've got all the in all the
submissions into into your system uh so
I'll I'll I'll be guided by I mean
personally it doesn't bother me but if
the if there's a busy time in the C in
the uh farming calendar in December and
we not not likely to get too many more
submissions better off closing it at 27
November and we can get on to our work
on December and January that's the the
property group and have a a summary
available in February uh for then cross
submissions on
that Council
Phillips yeah thank you worship I'm just
saying that um we received a letter from
the senior vice president of Federated
Farmers requesting four weeks and and
she will know whether or not 4we period
is enough time for them to get some more
submissions in and I'm sure if she
wanted six weeks she would have written
down six weeks and I and I feel pretty
obliging at four weeks and yeah we'll
get hopefully we'll get some more
submissions thank you councelor I'm not
sure if that was our suggestion or their
but it was on the lad regardless um any
F the
comments think we've got General support
for the motion as it stands
uh we have a over on a seconder any
further
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried thank you
counselors welcome back to the table
counselors uh number
11102 the Southern Museum and art
gallery annual
report uh would RX like to speak to the
sto nope any questions or comments on
this one
councilors uh councelor Dixon then
councelor
Reed it's just an observation actually
um because the audit is saying that
trust ability to continue as an ongoing
concern they are really concerned about
that they the accounts didn't include
the
assets and the auditor says that the
report is less than satisfactory so I
wonder if anyone can comment about that
it just seems a bit of a
concern uh councilor Phillips thank you
worship uh as part of the re Regional
Heritage committee um I could probably
make a comment on
this uh the SME group itself has now um
got a new board uh throughout the these
members are from throughout the country
um they're basically started off from
from scratch um this came up at our um
audit meeting last last week we have a
meeting on the 19th which is next week
um there'll be probably more discussion
about smag and its
ongoing structure and funding and stuff
like that and we intend to meet with the
SM the smag
board uh in
December um yeah so I'm more than happy
with what's happened and I think the
turnaround will be great great for
Southland thank you Council councelor
Reed um completely support councelor
Phillips and his comments um one thing I
did notice in the audit report was the
substantial increase in audit fees
something that our council is going to
be facing as well but um 2022 the audit
fees were
$866 this year there was $
17,5 one so that's you know the sort of
things that we're having to face as a
council as well so so
audit I don't really know how they can
justify that sort of increase but um I
guess that's up to them I'm sure our
Chief Financial Officer has had many
discussions around that but um very
interesting thank you counselor any
further comments on this
report could please have a move at this
report be
received uh councelor Phillips seconded
by councelor Reed any forther the
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say
I and against the motion is
carried item 12 uh page 133 minutes of
the matot community board meeting do we
have any questions or
comments or an update from councilor
Phillips uh nothing stands out at the
moment your worship only happy to answer
any questions just that uh I say can
thing on item number four the welcome
signs I have seen photos of them being
made on the
ground watch the
space so it's not actually a
myth I believe it was Christmas 2023
rather than Christmas 2022 wasn't
it how about
19 uh councelor read did you thank you
Mr May um a couple of things there I
noticed that um councilor Phillips
congratulated the three Waters boys on
the finalization of the water treatment
plant and I'd like to add to that as
well my congratulations it's been a big
project and they've done very well and
the other thing I see that tallk Park
applied for funding and their
application was successful and that's in
the tune of
775 $770,000
and um that's really good to see that
money being able to so well done Keith
you must have made a great
application well see councelor Reed um
and yeah well done well done Keith on
that
application any further
comments could I please have a move that
the minutes of the meeting held 18th
September be received councelor Phillips
seconded by councel Fraser I will put
the motion all those in favor please say
I and against the motion is is carried
item 13 page
137 minutes of the creative communities
assessment committee
meeting did we have any comments on that
meeting Council Reed yes thank you um
just it literally is just a comment um
it was quite a um busy little meeting
really and I'd just like to thank Susan
Jones our governance officer um there
was a bit of conflict and interest in
around the funding that came from the
festival fund um which was for a one-off
funding and there were was a lot of
debate around the table about it and
none of us really actually understood
that so Susan actually managed to
clarify all of the questions and uh yeah
it's always good to have an experienced
hand at the wheel thank you
Susan thank you counselor any further
questions or
comments could I please have a move
those minutes be received councelor Reed
seconded
by councelor Dixon I will put the motion
all those in favor please say I and
against the motion is carried summary of
the M Forum
meeting I will take the reports read and
happy to answer any questions if there
are
any no questions or
comments
see quite a few people scrolling so I'll
just give you a
second copies move the information be
received councilor Phillips seconded by
councelor
Stringer any
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is carried minutes of the
Great South joint shareholders committee
meeting uh again I will take the minutes
uh as read did we have any
questions no questions could I have a
move that that report be received uh
councelor mcdonell second by councelor
Gardine I will put the motion all those
in favor please say I and against the
motion is
carried item 16 page 175 the minutes of
the rule halls and domains
subcommittee do we have any comments on
this
meeting could I please have a move that
the minutes be received and that the
recommendations be ratified uh Council
me to now second by councelor Richard
mcf any further
discussion I will put the motion all
those in favor please say I and against
the motion is
carried uh that brings us to the end of
this portion of the meeting uh I'm going
to start a new tradition here of uh
closing out this section of the meeting
then reopening the in commmittee stuff
um as I tend to not get to the closing
prayer um so we'll be in uh Modi uh we
CER everyone uh thank you for coming
along we will take a 5 minute
information and then come back for the
in committee